hello everyone and welcome to the show
today we're driving
straight into the headlines that's right
it's time for drew's news and if news
were bagels
we try to be the everything and with me
at the desk is
my toasty little sesame seed ross
matthew
hi hi everybody
welcome back to drew's news your new
charcuterie board serving a fine
assortment of good news
cheeses and i've got a special guest
here to nosh the news board with me
she's a comedian actress author host and
winner of the critics choice award
for best comedy special one of my very
favorites michelle bouteau
[Applause]
it's time for drew's news the only news
program that misses you
when you don't watch it and with me at
the desk
my true blue news dude rossi ross
matthew yes hello
it's time for drew's news your news
fondue station
overflowing with melty gooey good news
and with me at the desk is a man who i'm
always gonna share my cheese with
rusty ross matthew
time for drew's news your all you can
eat good news buffet where doggie bags
are encouraged and with me at the desk
is my favorite friend
for a news feast it's rock matthew hi
everybody
it's time for drew's news playing all
the good news beats
on our good news bongos and with me at
the desk
a news man with a whole lot of rhythm
rusty roswell
hi guys
[Applause]
it's time for drew's news your new
sunday with good news cherries on top
and with me
at the desk is the second scoop in this
sunday it's rusty rusty
yeah that's right you're getting second
it's time for drew's news
your giant pot of news pasta loaded with
good news meatballs
and with me at the desk is my favorite
noodle
rossy slurpee roxy that didn't work out
at all
[Applause]
it's time for drew's news your good news
puppy dog that always brings in that
good newspaper
with me at the desk is a man who does an
excellent dog impression ross matthew
oh hi i think my i think my dog
impression is a little rough
it's time for drew's news where your
busy little news bees making that good
news honey and with me at the desk is
our green guru for the day
danny seah
[Applause]
it's time for drew's news the good news
soda fountain where the refills are
always free and with me at the desk is a
man
who loves his ice crush it's ross
matthews yes that's how i like my eyes
it's time for drew's news your daily
surf on that
gnarly good news wave and with me at the
desk is
my bodacious bud who's always crushing
it ross and the
crushing it it's time for drew's news
the little good news engine that could
and with me at the desk
he chugga chug
it's time for drew's news your daily
high five
in news forum and i'm here with veteran
tattoo artist
ryan ashley one of the very best in the
whole wide world
and always my trusty co-pilot rossi ross
matthews
[Applause]
it's time for drew's news your daily
scritchy scratch of that
good news itch and with me at the desk
is a man who'd never turn his nose up at
a back scratcher it's russ matthews yeah
it's time for drew's news we're your
trusty newshounds rounding up the fluffy
good news sheep
and with me at the desk is the newshound
with the best
news nose in town ross matthews
[Music]
it's time for drew's news your daily
dive for good news
pearls and with me at the desk is my
little mollusk
rossi ross matthews
it's time for drew's news your news
fanny pack
for good news on the go and with me at
the man is a man who
loves a stylish yet sensible bag ross
matthews
it's time for drew's news your daily
shimmy of those good news shoulders
and with me at the desk is human shimmy
yes i got it too
[Applause]
it's time for drizz news the only news
that feels like
finding a 20 in your pocket and with me
at the desk is human lucky penny
ross matthew hi everybody
it is time for trues news if news
programs had
tails ours would always be a wagon
um and with me at the desk is my
favorite news puppy ross nephew
[Music]